i won't stay silent
f1 has a problem
despite every campaign every slogan and
however often sir lewis hamilton calls
it out i won't stay silent against
racial discrimination and inequality it
just keeps happening some project wheels
and it happened to aiden whose entire f1
career
is in this box
when i was a kid this is all i wanted to
do seeing them on the tv with their big
hydraulic like guns
his family moved from south africa and
aged just 16 aiden started right at the
bottom as a cleaner at silverstone as he
worked his way up he learned how to
build bits of the cars for three teams
williams alpine and mclaren he worked at
aston martin's f1 team as a suppliers
agency contractor this february
what happened before even walking into
my work environment
that's when i was told
look if you've got a problem with how we
speak here
it's just how we speak
the main perpetrator piped up and first
first
first nickname
brownie which is that's when it started
and it went from brownie to [ __ ]
so when you can see how it slowly starts
escalating
just on the second shift how often would
the n word have been used
hourly hourly within like yeah that's
how
that wasn't referred to as 80 or
anything like that no i was called
and brownie that's what i was referred
to and aiden's story goes beyond racism
i disclosed to someone that i had a
boyfriend in my teen years and that was
it done for that split second everything
switched they tackled everything bit by
bit as soon as they they were clawing
away trying to trying to break me down
as just a man as an individual as a as a
human
the aston martin f1 team who have
four-time world champion sebastian
vettel in one of their cars say aidan's
contract was terminated due to poor
performance and poor timekeeping it was
unconnected they say to the
discrimination he suffered
aston martin racing said amr and its
supplier operate a zero tolerance policy
with regard to racism homophobia and all
types of discrimination we deal with any
allegations of this unacceptable
behavior seriously including thoroughly
investigating such claims and
sanctioning any individual who fall
short of our standards in this case the
complainant was rightly believed his
complaints were immediately acted upon
and appropriate sanctions were imposed
in line with our zero tolerance policy
we are in ongoing discussions with him
but for aiden this is bigger than just
his story
it's supposed to be a level playing
field it's supposed to be the one thing
here that gives everyone the opportunity
that's what i was sold as a kid that's
what we're selling all the kids that's
what we're selling the next generation
and if it's a lie then then what's the
point
he has now left the sport
despite everything it's a sport he says
he still loves
tom parmenter sky news northamptonshire